hey this is very very interesting a
majority of the country believes that
donald trump should be convicted
in his second impeachment trial which
starts tomorrow tomorrow february 9th is
the beginning
of the second impeachment trial of
donald trump in the senate and a
majority of americans now say
that they support a conviction for
donald trump
in the senate and that they support
trump being banned
from holding federal office again in the
future this is a new
abc news ipsos poll released yesterday
these are very different numbers than we
saw during donald trump's first
impeachment in the abc news washington
post poll
published in late january of 2020 that
was
the first impeachment trial 47 percent
of americans
then said trump should be convicted and
removed from office by the senate
in this latest poll 56 percent of
americans say that donald trump should
be convicted and barred
from holding office and uh this is
notable for a few different reasons most
importantly because in the united states
you don't get 56 percent when it's only
democrats i think i
i don't have the latest numbers in front
of me i think democrats only make up
about
it's in the low 30s i believe of
the united states the low 30s percent
are
democrats meaning to get to 56 you've
got a bunch of independents
as well as uh uh some republicans in
there as well so 56
say convict trump um and we are going to
see
uh i i don't believe there's any chance
we get a conviction but we are going to
see another
example of how the will of the people
is not reflected in what our elected
officials
do now i've spoken before about how the
senate is fundamentally anti-democratic
to begin with
the senate with two senators from
each state regardless of that state's
population
allows senators who represent only 17
percent
of the population to control the
majority of the votes or in some cases
160 votes are needed
to prevent the majority from actually
getting their way
so the it is it is a fundamentally
anti-democratic body
and it's important to remember that you
know the q anon wing of the republican
party
doesn't care that 56 of the country
wants trump convicted
um republicans who have already
prejudged
this impeachment trial and have already
decided they're not going to vote to
convict
they're not going to be swayed by what
their constituents think come on guys
swayed by what their constituents think
they're they're going to be swayed by
the interests of the party and their
donors um
and this is that's
we talk about the major issues in
american politics and
and sort of in the united states and of
course
campaign finance and how elections are
financed is a big part of that
the election system meaning the
electoral college plus first past the
post is a
big issue climate change is of course a
big issue
and generally speaking income inequality
access to health care because
if you don't know where your next meal
is coming from or you're sick and you
can't afford care
it's hard to be an activist for anything
that you care for
implicit in all of this is a belief
that many of us hold that representative
democracy
needs to be representative of the people
and we have
acutely a situation now princeton has
studied this we talked about it with tom
hartman on the program last week
we have yes an oligarchy but we also
don't have
representation in the sense that most of
us understand
it should work the majority of americans
want more stimulus checks and they
believe that the plan joe biden has put
forward is
the right plan they support that plan
and they support health care reform
and they don't think we should be
involved in many of the military
conflicts we're engaged in and it just
has it just doesn't matter
because politicians are representing who
someone else they're representing donors
they're representing lobbyists they're
representing industry they're
representing elites or whatever the case
may be
and a majority of americans increasingly
are not getting to decide now if
everybody voted
and not only if everybody voted but they
were informed you would be able to fire
some of these people but unfortunately
due to a lack of
media literacy political awareness
apathy
people being busy living their lives
which i also understand the system gets
perpetuated and we increasingly have a
non-democratic apparatus representing
the people
bigger issue than we can fix today but
we will be covering the trump
impeachment trial
starting tomorrow most of the country
wants trump convicted
it's not going to happen you know i'm
not going to lie to you i didn't lie to
you in january of 2020. we knew trump
wasn't getting convicted
trump's not getting convicted this time
either now i know some oh but that
that's the one other thing i wanted to
say
secret ballot a lot of people writing to
me saying david
if there were a secret ballot would
trump get get convicted
maybe but it's not going to happen and
we'll talk about why a secret ballot
won't happen
maybe on tomorrow's show start your day
and your new year off right with just
egg which is one of our sponsors you've
heard me talk about the importance of
having a diet that is
more heavily plant-based than it's
something i've done
over the last few years i've always
loved eggs
so it's great that there is a delicious
plant-based
version of egg with all the protein of
egg that just egg brings with it
but it's made from mung beans so it uses
98 percent less water
and causes 93 percent fewer carbon
emissions than a conventional
egg and just egg cooks and tastes
exactly
like a conventional egg i've tried it
for omelets
scrambled eggs french toast banana bread
pad thai anything you'd normally use
eggs for and i actually think if i
cooked something for a friend without
telling them
about just egg they wouldn't even know
the difference
find it in the egg aisle at your grocery
store
on amazon prime now or on instacart
and they also have a frozen version
perfect for breakfast sandwiches
just egg try it out